but I gotta tell you man if Ron is
hurting this much in the polls and
they're not course correcting I I think
that's a failure of leadership I think I
love his policy I think the reason Iran
is is kind of tanking is because Ron
doesn't have the Charisma people thought
that he was going to have like when he
gets onto the onto the national stage
people aren't like he's not magnetic
when he's on stage he doesn't have the
Charisma he's not he's not like uh uh
Barack Obama he's not Bill Clinton he's
not Donald Trump and those are three
people that had really really
significant Charisma and you there's an
argument that uh that bush had really
good Charisma as well so that could be
it but the a big part of that is people
like the idea that he was more stoic in
that he could be a version of Trump
without being more bombastic that was
the top but that doesn't work once you
actually have to come out and speak more
regularly just because that was an
argument doesn't mean that was actually
what the the country was going to feel